ARE W GOING TO TA OKD
TH OF THE T TO OVER
LAWS PASSE WAK
SUCOURT TRIKING
ROE V. WADE.
AS YY STATES ARE
ENACNG RESIC
OUTRIGHTANS WHILE OTHER ATES
ARE TR T ABORTION MORE
EASILYTO ANYONWH
GESS THEIR
CNIC
CORRESPOND
ILLED HER.AND ITGSE
COLLEGE. YOUR PLANS FOR RBLE  T
>> WAWAY.
>> KALEYHER SBD TO
LEARN SHE WAS .
ABUR MONTHS LATER  ANTMENT.
>> HE SAID THIS IS WHA
HEART LOOKS LIKE BUT
WHAT Y L
E WAS MISSING HEART
HER MEDICAL RECORDS SHOW
E FETURA SET CHROM AEVERE HEAR
DEFECT, ANS WERE
SMALL.
>> WILL DELIVER AND
Y WILLTE AND
PA
>>WAS
OCTHORN, H
HE MAY LIVE FOR A MINUTES,
DIE
H DOCTO COULD
COAVE RFORM ANRTION,ING  RECORDE
TAKEN WITH A PIENT YEAR AG
O M TO
E.
SHE  THE SAFEST
COURSE OF AC MOST HUMANEOU
ANGRY AN THANTTHAT I'M BEING TOA
NO MATTER AT.ING HIM TO TM M
HA P'S
SHE WAS AT SEVERAL
POTENTIALLADLY PCY
COMPLICATIONS.
BLOOD CLOTS, PRE-ECLAMPSIA
CONDITION THAT PLACES HER AT NTF
RISK OANTIAL
IMPAIRMENTBUT LAWMAKER
HAVEN'T SPELLED PANT EXAHAT MEA.
EXA THE
SITUATIONS WHEN ION CABE PROVID.
I OSITE.EXTREMELY RESTRICTIVANDL
THEY THREAN TOSO
MEDICAL LINS.
>> TED WCHD RISK LIFE AND GIVE
ULD DIQUKLR GO
OF STATE AND HAVE AN ABORTION.
HOW COULD YOU BE SO CRUEL
TO PASS A LA YOU KNOW WILLRT WO?
HE WAS GOING TO E FU
DE
SO HOW IS TH HUMANE?
TEXAS LAW PROHIBITS INE FROM PA
ABONCASES,THVE TO IN T
GIOUNDOLRS>> MY B HS OTECT ANDE
IF I'M NOTIGR  I
>> THEXIRECORDED THE BKALEY SLES
DE WERRAISED ITE
ANDFELT MORE BETRAYEDLA WE SO .
HEY WANT THAVE
BYUT'SH OD SOMETHING
WRAIN.AST TIME I SAWO T XAS RIG.
SHE SAID TS  SAFE.OWY AND CADE
DECIDE, ABIDE BYHAADVICE AND
TEXAS, LEAVE THEIR STND RISK LE
GA REACHE
AUORR SPONSORED THE -ABORTIO.